[Music]
in early 1828 Sojourner Truth approached
the grand jury of Kingston New York she
had no experience with the legal system
no money and no power in the eyes of the
court ignoring the jury's scorn truth
said she was there to fight for custody
of her five-year-old son Peter who'd
been illegally sold to an enslaver in
Alabama as the trial played out over the
next several months truth raised funds
strategize with lawyers and held her
faith finally in the spring of 1828
Peter was returned to her care but truth
spark was far from over
she would dedicate the rest of her life
to pursuing justice and spiritual
understanding truth was born into
slavery as Isabella bomb free in the
late 18th century in Ulster County New
York although New York State had
announced the abolition of slavery in
1799 the Emancipation Act was gradual
those who are currently enslaved were
forced to serve a period of indentured
servitude until their mid-20s throughout
this period in slavers repeatedly sold
bomb free tearing her from her loved
ones often she was explicitly prevented
from pursuing new relationships
eventually she married an enslaved man
named Thomas with whom she had three
children she was desperate to keep her
new family together but the slow
progress of abolition threatened this
hope bond freeze and slaver
John Dumont had promised to free her by
1826 when he failed to keep his word
bomb free fled for her safety during the
escape she was only able to rescue her
youngest daughter Sophia while her other
children remained in bondage it would be
two years before she regained custody of
Peter after that she would wait another
two years before she saw any of her
other children during this time bomb
free found solace in her faith and
became increasingly dedicated to
religious reflection after settling in
Kingston New York she joined a Methodist
community that shared her political
views she continued her practice of
speaking aloud to God in private and one
night her evening prayers took on even
more sacred significance
baan free claimed to hear the voice of
God telling her to leave Kingston and
share her holy message with others
though she never learned to read or
write bomb free became known as an
electrifying orator who speeches drew on
biblical references spiritual ideals and
her experience of slavery her sermons
denounced the oppression of African
Americans and women in general and
became prominent in campaigns for both
abolition and women's rights in 1843 she
renamed herself Sojourner Truth and
embarked on a legendary speaking tour
truth saw her journey as a mission from
God
her faith often led her to the nation's
most hostile regions where she spoke to
bigoted audiences as the only black
woman in the crowd truth was confident
God would protect her but some crowds
responded to her bravery with violence
during one of her sermons a mob of white
men threatened to set fire to the tent
where she was speaking in her memoir
truths were called stealing herself to
confront them have I not faith enough to
go out and quell that mob I felt as if I
had three hearts and that they were so
large my body could hardly hold them
she placated the men with song and
prayer until they had no desire to harm
her truth speeches impacted thousands of
people in communities across the nation
but her activism went far beyond public
speaking during the Civil War she became
involved with the Union Army recruiting
soldiers and organizing supplies for
black troops her work was so
well-regarded that she was invited to
meet President Lincoln she took the
occasion to argue that all formerly
enslaved people should be granted land
by the government truth continued to
travel and speak well into her 80s until
her death in 1883 she remained an
outspoken critic who fought for her
right to be heard in a hostile world
as truth once said I feel safe even in
the midst of my enemies for the truth is
powerful and will prevail for another
account of an enslaved woman who laid
her life on the line in the fight for
freedom and justice check out this video
on the epic feats of Harriet Tubman or
learn more about the women's suffrage
march of 1913 whose organizers were
directly influenced by truths work
[Music]